[Musique]
nathalie jose bonjour bonjour bonjour à
tous bonjour à tous les fouilles à les
fouilles à l'aise martiniquais
martiniquaise alors vous êtes candidate
aux élections législatives où vous
présenter sur la circonscription de fort
de france avec la liste pays a alors
qu'est ce qui motive votre candidature à
ce scrutin ben écoutez c'est dans la
droite lignée la continuité de ce que
nous avons fait depuis quelques années
maintenant puisque après mon engagement
à martinique citoyenne donc je me suis
présenté aux municipales à avec cette
alliance avec pays à marcenat d'eau
jean-philippe ni l'or et d'autres y aime
aussi qu'ils n'organisent mouvement
national et donc il nous semblait très
logique aujourd'hui de participer à ces
élections parce que nous avons entamé
une démarche nous avons entamé une
démarche de renouvellement du du champ
politique nous voulons will réenchanter
la politique et mettre d'autres
pratiques en mode en cours parce que
aujourd'hui on le voit avec les taux
d'abstention énorme aujourd'hui il ya un
véritable décalage à véritable fossé
entre les citoyens et la politique et
nous notre mission c'est de renouer ce
lien là avec les citoyens au travers de
la démocratie participative c'est notre
cheval de bataille faire les citoyens
participer à la vie politique et donc
nous nous attelons à ça alors si vous
êtes justement élus à l'assemblée
nationale quelles seront les deux ou
trois projets prioritaires que vous
souhaitez défendre pour l'ensemble de la
martinique du territoire alors bien sûr
il faut d'abord faire un constat puisque
on le sait aujourd'hui la situation mart
martinique ne cesse de se dégrader à on
a vu que depuis quelques années depuis
de nombreuses années déjà mais
particulièrement depuis les deux
dernières années de crise sanitaire
elles ont été particulièrement
difficiles pour nous d'autant plus qu'
on a eu
à subir déconfinement der confinement
des couvre feux
qui parfois ont été vécue de façon
injustifiée par la population et donc
aujourd'hui il faut arriver à se faire
entendre il faut que nous reprenions le
pouvoir sous nos propres réalités et
donc c'est dans cette optique c'est dans
cet objectif que nous visons l'assemblée
nationale pour pouvoir porter la voix
des martiniquais et pour pouvoir porter
la réalité martiniquaise à l'assemblée
et leur dire voici qui nous sommes et
voici ce que nous voulons et non pas
aujourd'hui des décisions qui sont
parfois injustifiées qui ne
correspondent pas à notre réalité des
décisions qui sont prises par un
gouvernement
élitiste parisien arrogant parfois oui
et qui nous imposent des décisions qui
ne nous conviennent pas donc
principalement notre objectif c'est de
nous faire entendre et de faire entendre
un point des martiniquais au delà de ça
nous avons élaboré des propositions de
loi bien sûr plusieurs propositions de
loi alors je ne vais pas vous parler de
toutes celles que nous avons élaborée
nous en avons quatre principales mais
parmi celles ci nous avons la politique
de la sécurité une proposition de loi
sur la sécurité parce que la violence
aujourd'hui
continue de prospérer dans la
circonscription dans laquelle vous vous
représentez celle de fort de france
celle de fort de france mais aussi sur
tout le territoire martiniquais vous
avez vu qu'il ya des communes qui
autrefois était très président paisible
comme grand rivière macouba est
aujourd'hui la violence arrivent jusque
là ça veut dire qu on est dans un
contexte qui est extrêmement compliqué
extrêmement difficile et qu'il faut y
faire face donc non ce que nous
demandons c'est plus d'effectifs pour
vous faire face à cette violence et puis
aussi des politiques de prévention il
faut absolument que l'on mette en place
des politiques de prévention pour la
jeunesse et ça ça va se faire à travers
la politique de la ville alors tout
simplement
sur sur cet axe là nous avons donc une
proposition de loi qui va s'appuyer plus
précisément sur les politiques de la vie
là pour
dans une loi-programme remettre à
remettre sur le devant de la scène un
plan d'urgence pour la jeunesse qui
avait été promis on a vu que lorsque les
jeunes sont allés sur des barrages
lorsqu'il ya eu ces émeutes et pillages
on l'a promis de s'occuper de leur a
promis un plan loi promis des contrats
aidés et aujourd'hui on n'a toujours
rien donc ce que nous demandons c'est la
reprogrammation de la politique de la
ville et la reprogrammation de la
politique de la ville parce que on
arrive au bout parce que la politique de
la ville elle fonctionne il ya des
dispositifs qui sont mis en place sur
plusieurs territoires en matière de
politique de la ville et qui ont montré
leur efficacité
le problème c'est que ces politiques ne
sont pas assez généralisé et nous nous
allons nous battre pour qu'elle soit
généralisé sur tout le territoire
martiniquais pour que enfin les jeunes
soient pris en compte comme à marseille
à marseille on a débloqué des milliards
on a débloqué un plan d'urgence pour la
jeunesse alors que la criminalité
proportionnellement est moindre donc ce
que nous demandons c'est que aujourd'hui
on s'occupe de notre jeunesse et pour
terminer avant de terminer qu'avez vous
à dire d'autre aux électeurs alors ce
que nous voulons dire aux électeurs
c'est que
en pleine crise sanitaire comme le
moment était très difficile il faut
qu'ils sachent que ce fort de france il
n'y avait pas de député le député en
place a choisi de laisser la chaise vide
vite tout simplement alors qu'on avait
besoin de lui donc aujourd'hui je crois
qu'il nous faut des hommes et des femmes
et je suis de celles là qui soit à
l'assemblée pour véritablement les
défendre défendre leurs convictions
défendre leurs intérêts leurs intérêts
principaux et mettre en place une équipe
qui pourra sauver les intérêts
martiniquais et qui pourra faire face à
ce gouvernement qui aujourd'hui est un
gouvernement arrogant méprisant et qui
ne nous écoute pas nous irons à
l'assemblée c'est que l'on nous écoute
merci la négligence
[Musique]